the fortune tellers is a new book by
washington post media reporter howard
kurtz
it argues that financial reporters have
power over wall street
and can affect such things as stock
prices and market movements
mr kurtz talked about his views at the
borders books and music located at new
york city's world trade center
it's 45 minutes
i in borders are very pleased to welcome
this afternoon reporter howard kurtz as
he discusses and signs copies of the
fortune tellers
inside wall street's game of money media
and manipulation
newly out from free press turning his
skeptical eye
on the business media revolution kurtz
widely recognized
as america's best media reporter exposes
the driving forces behind the financial
news on which so many depend
personal alliances rumor mongering and
manipulation
the fortune tellers is an eye-opening
account of an unseen world based on 18
months spent shadowing the most
influential
and colorful people in the world of
business and journalism
including james kramer of the street.com
christopher byron of the new york
observer
and prudential securities is star
commentator
ralph and compora the book illuminates
the conflicts of interest among wall
street analysts whose words can boost or
bash a stock
and their seductive relationship with
scoop hungry reporters
who rarely question whether these gurus
are right or wrong
kurtz reveals the justice spin has taken
over politics in america
so it has come to define the bull market
as well
howard kurtz is the media reporter for
the washington post and the author of
three previous books including the new
york times bestseller's spin cycle
inside the clinton propaganda machine he
is also the host of the weekly cnn
program reliable sources
and was named the nation's best media
reporter by american journalism review
he currently lives in chevy chase
maryland mr kurtz will discuss the
fortune tellers for about 30 minutes and
taking questions from the audience and
then he will sign copies of his books
which are available in the back please
join borders in welcoming mr
howard kurtz
thank you very much get organized here
my props down
well let me start by asking you all a
question um
how many of you are here because you are
deeply interested in me as an author
and how many just want to make a quick
buck okay so we get that on the table
uh under sec regulations i must request
that all our cell phones and beepers be
turned off no calling your broker in the
middle of the talk
that might be construed as selective
disclosure and in case you think that
the
stock that stock market analysts know
everything consider this
the beginning of this year on television
where else byron wean of morgan stanley
said that this fall bill bradley would
beat john mccain for the presidency
i hope that his portfolio does well in
the bradley administration
well if you're interested in the stock
market at all and who isn't these days
you've probably spent some time watching
cnbc and you've probably noticed that it
bears some resemblance to a sports
network there's a pre-game show
opening bell a color man a starting
lineup lots of statistics
a half-time report and a post-game
wrap-up it's about
putting points on the board in the form
of higher stock prices
every day somebody wins somebody loses
while this is no accident
cnbc is consciously modeled on espn's
sports center
and some of its biggest fans include
charles barkley
johnny bench john elway and andre agassi
who are not just jocks but very rich
jocks
but when it comes to financial advice
cnbc is not always a slam dunk
that's because the network while it uh
generally does a good job and has some
very good reporters
uh turns over its airwaves to a start a
steady parade of fund managers and wall
street analysts who advice whose advice
is not only contradictory
but sometimes turns out to be flat wrong
and because financial journalists
everywhere
lots of organizations do something that
is really allowed
in other parts of the news business they
report rumors
even bogus rumors sometimes on the
self-justifying theory that rumors move
the market
and because these fortune tellers some
of whom have become pretty big
celebrities
sometimes have blatant conflicts of
interest that are rarely discussed
now you see these flaws in all the
financial media uh you see them in the
slew of
financial magazines i brought a few
here today to give you the flavor of the
sort of get rich quick atmosphere with
which
these magazines try to hook you here's
money magazine
today's hottest tech stocks 10 great
investors abby cohen's top stocks
here's smart money the 10 best mutual
funds
here's another money seven best new
funds compared to last month's
all-star investors have got shaq on the
cover
pillow talk oh wait that's george
magazine
cindy crawford put these away um
and you also see uh this this sort of
frenzied environment i'm talking about
uh in the explosion of internet sites
from the street.com to
cbsmarketwatch.com
to jagnotes.com jag notes include
something called a rumor room
to cnn and cnn fn and bloomberg and
other television outlets
they all have a vested interest in
trotting out experts in trumpeting the
hottest stocks the best mutual funds the
surefire investment that can make you
rich tomorrow
if only you subscribe tune in or log on
cnbc though is the thousand pound
gorilla of business news and each day is
cast as an episode of who wants to be a
zillionaire
only there are no lifelines and if you
lose regis doesn't just send you home
you take a major hit to your bank
account
turns out it's not so easy to make a
pile of dough on wall street at least
not as easy as the self-proclaimed gurus
would have you believe
my own first up and up close and
personal encounter with wall street was
october 19
1987. i was the new york bureau chief
for the washington post
and like most americans i didn't know a
heck of a lot about the stock market but
the market was crashing that day
and my assignment was to hang with a
trader who was trying to save his rear
end as wall street seemed to be
collapsing
i wound up spending the afternoon with a
guy named john mulhern who seemed to me
to be just icy cool
as the market plunged 22 percent and he
was losing millions of dollars
now months later mulhern was arrested
for waving a gun and threatening to kill
legendary trader ivan boesky
who he believed had implicated him in an
insider trading case
wall street i concluded was one crazy
place
in those days few ambitious reporters
wanted to cover business it seemed like
a backwater a realm of dry statistics
and quarterly earnings reports
fortune and forbes were considered kind
of trade publications there were a
handful of business shows on the air
such as cnn's moneyline but otherwise
television
avoided the arena unless there was a
market crash or some other calamity
the journalistic action was in politics
crime
sports anywhere but business by the time
i began work on the fortune tellers the
landscape had been
utterly transformed business journalism
was hot nearly everyone cared about wall
street thanks to
401k retirement plans and online trading
and a cultural revolution in which half
of american families were now invested
in the market
new financial magazines and websites
were springing up seemingly by the hour
ceos like jeff bezos steve case and meg
whitman have become cult figures
two cable networks cnbc and cnn fn
covered the markets every burp
all day long celebrities like you've
seen these ads william shatner
phil jackson don rickles lily tomlin
were making dot com commercials
even howard stern was talking about the
market you couldn't get on an airplane
without seeing the latest dow and nasdaq
numbers flashing on the seat in front of
you
all of which raised for me some pretty
intriguing questions
who among this steady parade of analysts
fund managers and commentators could we
really trust
was this explosion of financial advice
worth a damn
and what role did journalism play in a
world where every hiccup could send a
stock hurtling toward the stratosphere
or into the toilet now journalists to be
sure are important in the world of
politics in my last book spin cycle
which i had the brilliant foresight to
publish right after the monica lewinsky
story broke
actually it was kind of a lucky accident
bill clinton and al gore and the white
house staff spent
endless huge amounts of time trying to
influence the press
but no single reporter has a great deal
of power to set the political agenda but
in the financial realm
business reporters are players what they
say
moves stocks sometimes instantaneously
but they get spun
too and just as important they are
sometimes a conveyor belt for passing on
the spin
of wall street hotshots the results are
not often pretty
the advice served up by many of these
fortune tellers is not only
contradictory but often wrong
almost no one for example predicted the
painful crash last april
in both the dow and the nasdaq that
permanently damaged many internet
companies
and probably cost some of you some money
but almost no one in the media holds
these folks accountable the press often
fails to blow the whistle
on blatant conflicts of interest as wall
street analysts tout the stocks of
companies that their own firms
are either doing business with or hope
to snag as clients
the talking heads themselves are often
influenced by cozy relationships with
their sources
that's true in other fields as well but
financial journalists
with their scoops and their stories can
slice billions of dollars off a
company's net worth
in a matter of minutes here's an example
last march reporter steve frank said on
cnbc's business center
that ebay and yahoo were holding secret
talks about a partnership and possibly a
merger
uh while frank cautioned that his
anonymous source put the odds of a
partnership of no more than 50 50
ebay soared in after hours trading from
211 dollars a share
to 235 dollars but the very next morning
on cnb squawk box
they were forced to backtrack london's
financial times was reporting that the
talks the supposed talks
had broken down the previous week these
two companies talk all the time
steve frank said all these companies
talk all the time what then was the big
exclusive
the market got the message in a hurry by
days and ebay had dropped 21 and a
quarter points and yahoo had fallen
10 and a quarter points the deal by the
way never happened
just the other week as many of you i am
sure know bloomberg news
followed by dow jones the street.com and
other business news heavyweights
got badly taken in by a criminal hoax
bloomberg bloomberg reported on a press
release
from a fiber optics company called
emulex still sounds like a laxative to
me
saying that its ceo had resigned and had
planned to restart its
restate its earnings for the last two
years and was under investigation by the
sec
emulex stock dropped a staggering 62
percent
in just 15 minutes but the press release
was a total fake
now did bloomberg or dow jones or anyone
make a phone call to confirm with the
company what turned out to be this bogus
news no
why because no one wants to get scooped
even by seconds
in this hyper competitive very intense
high stakes world
last week a former employee of internet
wire which puts
pr releases on the wire for new services
was charged in a scam which cost
investors some two and a half
billion dollars now i described in the
book how bloomberg was the victim of an
earlier fall story just months earlier
about two companies merging that one
employee voted on a fake
bloomberg web page without bloomberg's
knowledge you would think the news
service would have learned from that
incident that these things
need to be double checked here's another
example henry blodgett
star analyst for merrill lynch and a
major internet cheerleader
urges people to buy e-toys and the stock
unfortunately drops by 95 percent
budget urges people to buy amazon he
became famous in fact by predicting a
great surge for amazon less than two
years ago
and this year amazon's stock has dropped
by two-thirds
down even below the level of his 1998
prediction
finally he downgrades it after many
other analysts have done so
but the next time blidget is on
television is he grilled about being
wrong
largely the answer is no television
cares only about what stocks are going
to do today and tomorrow and next week
and television of course needs a steady
parades of articulate wise men to
pontificate
about the market want more ralph
akampura the raising raging bull at
prudential securities
makes broad predictions about the
direction of the market in the summer of
1999 akampura said the dow which was
then about 11 000
would hit twelve thousand five hundred
to thirteen thousand by the end of the
summer
when that didn't happen he said the dow
would reach that mark by the end of the
year
but last fall as the market ran into
some turbulent weather
i can pour it to the u-turn he said the
dow could drop as low as 8 900.
well that never happened but the
akanpura turned bullish again
when the dow finished 99 a little under
11 500
ralph said it could hit 13 500 to 14 000
by the end of this year
well we've got about 3 000 points to go
maybe we'll make it
by the way akapura also said the nasdaq
would hit 5000 by the end of this year
and it happened within weeks
and then the nasdaq crashed down almost
to 3 000 before clawing its way
back to four thousand now ralph and poor
says he's like a weatherman he's a
technical analyst who has to change his
forecast when it starts to rain or snow
others see him as more of a weather vein
turning with the wind
maria bought a romo and i'll tell you
who she is the cnbc reporter perhaps
better known as the money honey
she has the power to make stocks dance
nobody works harder i've watched her
work the phones in that little booth
above the floor in the new york stock
exchange
chatting up her sources right up until
the second she goes on the air
i've also watched her down on the floor
where traders are always bumping her
when she's on the air it's like kind of
like the d
train at rush hour there and what bar
aroma does in the crucial 90 minutes
before the market opens at 9 30
is to report and trumpet the upgrades
and downgrades of various wall street
firms
now as we've seen with henry blodget
these downgrades sometimes come long
after the stock is in the toilet
and the upgrades are offered wrong too
morgan stanley or payne weber or goldman
sachs
predicts the stock will go up maybe it
does maybe it goes down
but bonoromo never comes back with any
kind of scorecard how did these folks do
she just reports the next day's haul
of hot information so she is the very
hard-working queen of wall street but in
some ways also a captive of the street
still her influence is enormous one of
those watching her reports very closely
is jim cramer
the wild and crazy wall street trader
and co-founder of the street dot com
early one morning i write in the book
cramer's merrill lynch broker called him
with the news that the firm was
upgrading micron technology
it's a company that makes a
semiconductor and computer products
that's going to be huge kramer said even
though the analyst was some no name he'd
never heard of
why said the broker we're not really
important on micron yes ed kramer but
somebody at your company speaks to maria
bartoromo
kramer's hedge fund at the moment was
sitting on a hundred thousand shares of
micron
just as cramer had anticipated water
roma quickly touted the merrell upgrade
on the air
soon after the market opened micron
jumped three points and cramer
dumped 15 000 shares knowing that lots
of buyers would come in
riding the maria wave and this was
absurd he thought investors will quickly
sort out the truth
the stock quickly crested and began
falling back to earth
cramer who liked the company long term
bought back the shares after micron had
dropped back three points back near its
original price now maria's hype was gone
he had turned a quick forty five
thousand dollar profit by calibrating
the power
of cnbc columnist dan dorfman
often touts mergers on jag notes dot com
one of a slew of new financial websites
which i mentioned also has a rumor room
for anonymous tips
uh here one of his stories last year
began reports are buzzing on wall street
that the chase manhattan corporation is
in exploratory talks
to buy brokerage kingpin merrill lynch
and company
cnbc quickly reported that the rumor was
untrue but it didn't matter
merrill lynch's stock jumped 21 over the
next two days
two months later the wall street
journal's heard on the street column
said that talk is again swirling on wall
street
that merrill lynch was open to a deal of
some kind with chase manhattan or
american international group
we're still waiting and in fact just the
other day i
brought along this new york post
headline markets rocket on rumors of j.p
morgan merger uh jp morgan's said to
have been up
um about 95 points on this on this rumor
i haven't checked the market today but
so far it hasn't happened maybe if it
happened this morning we'll have to
correct this before the talk is over
now uh businessweek has a writer named
jean marshall some of you may be
familiar with him and he often gives
stocks a pretty strong bump with his
inside wall street column
when marshall talked up a firm called
earthlink network it shares zoomed by
263 percent the next day
but the marshall effect can quickly wear
off especially when he cites fund
managers who are obviously trying to
pump up their stocks
marshall quoted one investor as saying
that a firm called graphics
zone would become one of the biggest
music sites on the web
over the next six months the stock
dropped by 88 percent and was booted out
of the nasdaq index
but i haven't gotten to the most
interesting part of the fortune tellers
my extensive painstaking research has
uncovered that one of the most striking
features of wall street is
half the people there can't stand the
other half for all the billion dollar
bets and the limos lined up outside and
the traders in their 3 000
italian suits shouting into cell phones
wall street often resembles nothing more
than a snooty high school with all these
little cliques
whispering and gossiping about everyone
else and that can have an effect on the
news coverage
we'll take jim cramer probably the most
fascinating character i've ever written
about
high intensity fast talking talks faster
than me for example
very manic guy a kramer trade stocks he
talks about stocks
he writes about stocks seven or eight
times a day in his column on the street
dot com
and in his column for new york magazine
sometimes he gets into ethical scrapes
over these multiple roles
kramer makes a bundle he made a bundle
off dot com stocks last year
but his own internet company the street
dot com has plummeted in value from a
high of 71 dollars when it went public a
little more than a year ago
to about eight dollars now cramer wants
to tell you what he thinks about the
market
every minute there was no television and
no internet he would probably go
door-to-door
but kramer also loves a good fight he's
uh kind of ticked off at cnbc which
booted him off the popular show squawk
box
last year he doesn't like fox news
channel which aired the street.com show
until a couple of months ago
when cramer helped yank the program and
he and fox wound up suing each other
he doesn't like dow jones where he's
once a distant stockholder taking on the
management
he had a huge fight with his best friend
marty parris who's the owner of the new
republic
and the other founder of thestreet.com
and the two
savage each other for months he doesn't
like dan dorfman or gene marshall and he
ridicules both of them in his columns
he used to like maria botaromo but now
he's kind of soured on her
and he doesn't like alan abelson the
veteran column and columnist at barons
well here's what kramer says about
abelson what i cannot stand is the
arrogance of the man who leads off
barons every week
and the contempt with which he holds
those of us who have been right instead
of wrong
his scorn of those of us who have gotten
it right had made money these last 15
years
that he has been a bear is utterly
contemptible stop his ravings from
polluting another year of financial
journalism kramer clearly doesn't pull
his punches
well here's what abelson says about jim
cramer kramer the television personality
an unfailing and unformidable threat to
coherence
kramer the writer a threat to objective
journalism since he is an unremitting
practitioner
of subjective journalism with only one
subject himself
kramer the hedge fund manager says
abelson manifestly a threat to the
financial well-being of his limited
partners
he wasn't short someone who never stops
talking but never says anything
but it's not just kramer mark haynes the
acerbic host of squawk box has
quite a low opinion of al ralph akampura
whenever akampur makes a new forecast
haines and his crew are merciless there
goes ralph again what does he know
wasn't he wrong last time
and this makes akampura very very mad
people like haines he says have turned
market coverage into a carnival
they have no concept of what he does
it's technical analysis he's always
wrong always a jerk mark haynes just a
mad dog
akapura got so angry in fact that for
months first he complained to cnbc
and then he started boycotting the
network and the feud goes on
there are battles within networks as
well squawk box if you haven't seen it
is a very funny show
mark haynes and his sidekicks nickname
kahuna and the brain
sit around and talk about star trek or
wendy's hamburgers when krispy kreme
went public they scarfed down donuts on
the set
sounds like a good idea and when heinz
announced that it was making green
ketchup
they all got together put on blindfolds
and did a taste test to see if they
could tell the red ketchup
from the green ketchup for the record
they all failed
another thing they do is they make fun
of wall street analysts when a bunch of
analysts downgrade a stock after it has
already started to slide
they show footage of a group of penguins
waddling along
in unison in fact dave david faber also
known as the brain told me that
one time he was walking down the street
perhaps not too far from here
and an analyst just started booing him
on the street apparently displeased with
his on-air commentary
well some months ago the ratings dipped
a bit and cnbc management cracked down
no more fooling around no more goofy
videotape no more
penguins and mark haynes and company
were not too happy they began making
subversive little comments on the air
like you do when the teacher's back is
turned in high school
they complained that cnbc was run by
former local news guys who
were ordering up a local format complete
with a weatherman they didn't really
understand
what squawk back was and the gang began
saving the emails that came in
here are a few of them whoever's bright
idea it was to ruin mark haynes kahuna
and the brain it's gonna backfire
you guys may as well jump off the
iceberg if there's no humor left
bring back the penguins the brain and
kahuna if i want solemn
business-like presentations i can watch
cnn fn
and my personal favorite congratulations
you've made squawk box as dull as a bob
dole infomercial on penile dysfunction
management got the message lifted the
ban and the ratings reached new highs
now there's one other thing that the
fortune tellers has in common with my
last book spin cycle and that is the art
of the leak
only instead of clinton white house
aides its corporate ceos and their flags
whispering to their favorite reporters
in an effort to shape the coverage take
doubleclick the big internet advertising
firm when doubleclick ceo kevin o'connor
was buying a company called abacus
for a billion dollars give it take some
small change he had his spokeswoman
leaked the news to one of their favorite
wall street journal reporters
that produced a favorable story that got
o'connor booked the next morning on cnbc
cnn fn and bloomberg tv a few weeks
later when doubleclick was buying
another firm called netgravity
o'connor called the same play the news
was leaked to the same wall street
journal reporter
which produced another favorable story
with a suitably upbeat quote
from kevin o'connor the thing about
these leaked stories that is that
critics are almost never quoted
because the reporter doesn't want to
risk losing the exclusive by calling
around
for reaction now don't get me wrong
there are without question
plenty of honest hard-working
journalists digging up good information
from the far
corners of the business world and there
are plenty of investors who have smartly
used such information
to make lots of money in this long bull
market but it would be a significant
improvement if more media outlets
resisted the temptation
to engage in the kind of hype and rumor
mongering in an attempt to stand out
from the increasingly boisterous crowd
the broader problem may be the
self-promotional drumbeat
sounded by so many of these outfits the
notion that only they can give you the
greatest mutual funds the best deals the
hottest tips
the shortest route to tomorrow's big
payoff yes
they provide solid solid information and
yes some of it is valuable
but they are also acting as carnival
barkers trying to drag consumers inside
the tent with promises of death defying
stunts
the good news is that the internet age
and the communications revolution has
allowed the average person with a modest
401k
plan access to the same lightning quick
information
as the high-powered wall street insiders
but ordinary folks must understand that
this information is sometimes suspect
sometimes tainted sometimes little more
than gossip
the market after all is inherently
unpredictable
and betting on the fortune tellers is
risky business
thank you very much
i would be happy to take some questions
you sir uh you haven't mentioned uh
kaiser uh or abby joseph cohen
uh are they amongst the legitimate types
that you refer to
well i don't say any of these people are
illegitimate uh they're uh
i just say that you uh that sometimes
their accuracy is less than a hundred
percent i must say that abby joseph
cohen
um it is harder to criticize her because
in the last several years
her forecasts about the broader
direction of the market not necessarily
about individual stocks
have been very very accurate uh i do
talk about lewis rue kaiser in the book
i mean he in a way is the granddaddy of
financial television with wall street
week on pbs
which has been on for some 30 years now
on friday night he is rather disdainful
interestingly enough
of cnbc and cnn when he calls these
minute-by-minute cable television ticker
shows
he thinks it's important to kind of step
back
take a deep breath and take the long
view because you know
he is right in the sense that most um
most analysts who are not trying to sell
you something uh believe that uh buying
and holding quality stocks and companies
that you believe is good long-term
investment
is the best strategy the whole
breathless nature of a lot of the cable
shows is kind of the trigger finger
approach where you know you got to get
online call your broker and buy
something now because it might pop 20
points or it might go down
before you can buy it but the
in some ways rue kaiser
is not able to keep up with with the
manic real-time nature
of of online trading because he comes on
once a week after the market has already
closed nobody can act on any advice
that ralph akampur or abby joseph cohen
or anybody else who comes on his show
gives
until monday morning and so i think a
lot of people being more impatient
or just um wanting to sort of get in the
game while they're getting as good
are turning to um more real-time sources
of information
so that they can trade stocks without
having to wait until an entire weekend
pass
there's a conflict between the first
amendment and investor protection
i know there have been already lawsuits
against some of these
dot-com outfits that uh brought out the
emulex story and of course the
officers weren't open when the story
came out it was like seven o'clock
california time do you think the sec has
to come up with some rules of liability
or how do you think the courts ought to
come out
you know i'm totally total rumors that
we're not checked at all
should there be liability to the
investors who sold
the question is whether there is a
conflict between the first amendment
and protecting the rights of investors
and whether or not there needs to be a
stricter regulation in this area
in fact um in what i would call a
related area the securities and exchange
commission just passed a new rule over
vociferous objection
by many on wall street uh and there have
been kind of a crusade of bloomberg news
to get this rule passed and it's a rule
against what's called selective
disclosure
and that means that um if a hotshot um
brokerage firm has a conference to which
they invite
um uh corporate executives and maybe
um selected analysts those analysts
can't disclose
and that's in that gathering vital
information
non-public information as the regulators
would call it about the market if they
haven't already shared it with the rest
of the world because it gives some
investors
an unfair advantage and of course that
news often gets leaked to one or more
uh television shows or websites and
people can act on it which is great if
you're getting in on on the hot
information not so great if you're an
investor
who for example is holding the stock and
you're not getting the bad news that
might affect that stock
i don't think other than the obvious
remedy uh
that people are always free to sue news
organizations that they believe have
acted recklessly or irresponsibly
that curtailing the freedom of the media
to report
is the answer at least not in the
country that values the first amendment
i in fact think that that hoaxes
outright criminal hoaxes
such as one involving pair gain
technologies which i write about in the
fortune tellers in this more recent
fiasco involving emulex which was
carefully selected because it was a
california company
understanding that their offices would
not be open when the market opened in
new york
therefore it would be hard for the news
organizations to confirm the
origin of this bogus press release i
think that is more
of a rare or occasional problem i think
the much greater problem
is this reporting of rumors and
speculation about these two companies
may merge and
microsoft may have a down quarter uh
that sort of thing because
you can't quite show that it's false
somebody is saying it it is
chatter on the street and chatter on the
street moves the market
but what troubles me is when news
organizations particularly ones with the
great reach of
of television give a kind of a
uh a gravitas or an amplifying effect to
these rumors by reporting them so that
millions of investors might act on them
and the fact is many of these supposed
mergers that we keep hearing about
um often don't seem to materialize now
once in a while one does and it's a big
one and if you got it on the stock
you can make a lot of money but it's a
dangerous game and i think also going to
your point a dangerous game for the news
organizations aside from whether they
get sued
they are in the business of selling
credibility if you have to think twice
about what you read on the bloomberg
wire or what you see on cable shows
or what you read on the street.com then
they've suffered a major hit and a
couple more of these
mulx fiascos and i think they understand
their credibility will
not so not so it will rather rapidly be
eroded
on wall street those that say don't know
and those that know don't say
but there was an expression about
teachers those that don't know teach
right
my question to you really is
nobody forces that person to react to
that news
okay versus the journalist or the
investor no no the investor
and i don't see how you can help hold
these folks accountable because this
really is an evolution of
i've worked here on wall street for 25
years there's always rumors
it used to spread by the telephone now
every broker has cnbc in his office
okay it's just an evolution and i don't
think you can hold these people any more
accountable
than you can hold the people that
produce violent movies in hollywood
accountable for the actions of some
people
i'd like your comment on it okay uh the
question just briefly was whether or not
since there have always been rumors even
the days of the telegraph
uh that move stocks whether uh the
journalists who
who repeat or report uh what they hear
in terms of street speculation can
really be held accountable if investors
uh decide to take it upon themselves to
trade to buy or sell
those stocks and i guess i would hold
journalists to a higher standard yes
we everybody needs to understand right
up front and mark haynes of cnbc is very
forceful on this point he says you know
it sounds rather cold but anybody who's
trading out there based on what they see
on my program um
is is putting themselves at risk you
know you're an adult
it's and you've got to make decisions
about the quality of the information
and whether you want to buy a piece of
these companies and you can't just
blindly expect everything that is said
on cnbc to turn into
a financial winner if you're going to to
buy that stock
having said that um in every other field
and with with trump family every other
part of journalism i usually write about
journalism and politics and journalism
and
lots of other endeavors there's a great
effort made to avoid reporting on rumors
there are lots of things that people
museums have heard or think they heard
or somebody's friend told them
and sometimes through the internet
or tabloids or a reporter with
less than high standards these things do
seep into the mainstream media but
generally we try to avoid them
the difference here is and i understand
the thinking the thinking is the rumors
out there somebody's buying and selling
based on it
why not let the rest of the world in on
it but i think that
because the market is so fragile and
because
in this lightning quick age these
financial journalists have so much
influence and because because stocks can
pop 20 30 40
in either direction based on some of
this chatter
that media organizations that just sort
of act as a conveyor belt
for whatever chatter they are hearing
are are basically contributing to the
problem and i think undermining their
credibility in the process
but you know you learn as a savvy
consumer to make distinctions
you learn for example that if you watch
a guy like joe kernan on cnbc who i
happen to like
he didn't go for the mlx hoax everybody
had it bloomberg had it dow jones had it
he's live on television
the stock is down 40 or 50 percent they
report that the stock is down and kernan
doesn't tell you why
he says we're still checking on this
because he knows from his experience
that this is an odd way for a company to
announce this kind of dramatic news
about the ceo residing
it hasn't been carried on any other news
service he holds back
and he was the only one that i looked at
that didn't fall into the trap of saying
it's out there let's report it
and then a half hour later sorry never
mind it turns out to be a completely
bogus hulk so you learn to make
distinctions about who you trust
who's careful and who is a little bit
quick on the trigger
excuse me what's your opinion on the
analysts who refuse to say sell because
they will not be invited back to those
company meetings this i'm getting
from yahoo finance if you look at it
they always say hold
or buy or strong buy they never say sell
that is a terrific question the question
is what do we think about analysts who
never say sell and the most
shocking single statistic not anybody
works on wall street but certainly to me
in researching
the fortune tellers is this figure 99
and a half percent of all
recommendations by wall street analysts
are some form of buy now
you could take the view that these are
really smart guys and all these stocks
are worth buying
if you look at the up and down
volatility of the market you might
conclude otherwise
i think there's several factors that
work here and it is complicated
one is that some analysts have told me
henry blodgett for example has told me
that he's under great pressure because
he's so widely followed on stocks like
amazon
and aol and other high-tech companies
not to downgrade a stock because
the mere act of his downgrading it even
if he's down you know there's a lot of
euphemisms in this
nobody ever says sell anymore you go
from a strong buy to a buy or a buy to a
long term accumulate
savvy investors know let's head for the
exits even though that never uses the
four-letter
s word cell but budget and others
maintain
that they don't want to sort of cause a
stampede they don't want to yell fire in
a crowded theater
and so that when by the time they get
around to downgrading a stock not
necessarily saying selling it but just
taking it down one notch
on the uh on the linguistic scheme
uh at that point the stock is probably
already down 20
30 40 50 70 percent there are lots of
examples of that
and that's one reason i think that
people are becoming um
somewhat wary of these analyst
recommendations even though they look
like very smart guys when you see them
day after day on tv and tv needs them
uh to fill up that air time and to have
the appearance of expertise on these
stocks
but there's another reason it's even
more troubling and that is
i think you alluded to it in your
question that some analysts come under
great pressure from their own firms
not to be too negative toward a client
in other words there's investment
banking business between merrill lynch
prudential goldman sachs
payne weber and the companies whose
stocks are being talked about
now a couple of analysts have gotten
fired for being too candid for saying in
my
opinion after doing all this research i
think this company has problems
that can get you bounced out the door
there are some incidents examples of
that in the book
and when that happens to one analyst or
two analysts you can be sure a lot of
others are getting the message
sometimes the pressure is more subtle
sometimes it's more insiduous
but i do think that it's a factor that
investors have to take into account
when they're judging um the opinion the
the
expertise of analysts just as they would
take into account the opinions of fund
managers
who come on and say i like microsoft i
like e-toys
i like infoseek and by the way my fund
owns
millions of dollars of that particular
stock you have to take those things into
account sometimes in the
in the great din and the great echo
chamber that the media has become these
days
those kind of distinctions and caveats
get lost
someone else want to jump in here you
sir
as a corollary to that question could
you go into the whole issue of the of
the state
of wall street research where so much of
the
research and analysis that's purported
to be
dispassionate opinions on buy this stock
because point a b c
is going to go up for these reasons as
opposed to the
interaction between the allegedly
independent and free thinking analysts
and the investment banking business of
the brokerage firms that employ them to
drum up much bigger investment banking
revenues
question is about the state of wall
street research and the allegedly good
word
uh independent or objective analysis
that's supposed to be performed
by the people who are paid lots of money
by these firms to rate
the um the progress and the prognosis
for various stocks
uh ryan sana of cnbc is one of the
characters in my book told me that when
he
got into this business 20 years ago he
had a very high opinion of wall street
researchers because they were just
a fount of great information about the
you know what was in the guts of the
company's report and they would call
suppliers to find out if the product was
moving and they would
they would go get out of the road and
they would do research and some of them
still do
and in sauna says there were basically
three ratings buy hold and sell
well now of course as we just discussed
you have the euphemisms about long-term
accumulate because nobody wants to use
the cell word
and also in insane's view he feels and i
feel and many people have looked at this
field
that the research is less trustworthy in
many cases there are some firms that do
nothing much research they don't have
investment banking clients
and therefore there's no question of a
hidden agenda feel that the research is
less trustworthy because
more of these more of these analysts
someone who are making millions of
dollars a year it's a big investment in
them
are basically in the business of selling
their banking services their rainmakers
they got to bring in the clients
and they have to balance sometimes
honestly sometimes i would say
under severe pressure the interests of
their own credibility what they're
telling investors what they're telling
the public
and the interests of their own
want to lose the banking business i'll
use a blodget to get an example not to
pick on him there are many
less well-known analysts who are in this
situation but
he used to work uh for a firm i believe
called cibc oppenheimer
he made the call on amazon 1998 that it
would go up by two thirds and
partially fueled by the hype surrounding
that call it did it just skyrocketed
through the target
he then got hired by merrill lynch for a
much more prestigious job presumably for
a lot more money
and he replaced the guy who had been at
merrill lynch who had been covering the
same stock amazon who said amazon was
worth
one eighth as much as henry blodgett
believed it was worth
now what does that tell you about
merrill lynch either it tells you that
they decided the old guy was wrong the
new guy was right or maybe
it tells you that merrill lynch was
interested in becoming a serious player
in the dot-com business
and getting the banking business from
some of these high-tech companies
who they hope would speak the same
language as their analyst
so as as the analysts they just hired so
again we come back to the question of
fortune tellers
are fallible uh they are contradictory
they sometimes have conflicting
agendas some journalists do a good job
of highlighting that many do not and
investors
obviously have a need to be cautious and
i think as we go through some of these
hoaxes and scares and episodes of hype
at least some investors are learning
that sometimes painful lessons
the question is whether anyone was made
to answer for the emulax hoax of a
couple weeks ago
well the fbi did arrest a gentleman who
was
the perpetrator or the alleged
perpetrator of the hoax who had written
the bogus press release he was a former
employee of a company called internet
wire
which is like pr newswire and business
wire
it's a new company that puts out press
releases to news organizations like
bloomberg and
cnbc and the street.com and it's
supposed to check these things but he
did it in such a way that it was not
checked
i understand there are already some
lawsuits pending and
you know the sec will continue to
investigate um but i do think that
there's always going to be fraud in a
market that is nothing new
uh what is new i think is the speed with
which these things can be perpetrated
given
the high impact of the real-time
financial journalism outlets
what troubles me more since you can
never completely 100 guard against the
possibility of being hoaxed
is the more subtle uh forms such as when
cnbc says ebay and yahoo are in talks
the stock goes up the talks turn out to
be not very serious or not very real
the stock goes down um you can say the
stock is bouncing around and eventually
finds its level but if you're the guy
who bought the stock when it suddenly
had to run up and suddenly it's down 20
points
you're not too happy that explanation
because you worry about your portfolio
as you should
start a conversation and it'll go up uh
anyone can send a message about a stock
in a chat room and sometimes
people who um post messages in these
chat rooms which are increasingly
influential a lot of people follow them
um they have a reason for wanting a
stock to go down maybe they want to
short the stock they have a reason for
winning stock to go up maybe they
already own a big batch
the thing about these chat rooms they're
very interesting i've checked them out
myself is
you know you got these little people
with anonymous screen names you know you
don't know what you're getting obviously
you want to exercise some caution
corporations interestingly enough some
of them are going after
people who they believe are doing these
what they regard as slanderous postings
on the internet about their company
sometimes suing america online or some
other internet provider to find out the
identity
of the people who are going online in
their view to trash their company
which shows you how seriously the
corporate executives take this
new online world i think we probably
have time for one more
sure can you discuss what you see
in in the future as it relates to media
you know the growth of
internet tv uh more publications as it
relates to the market
and whether uh the the effect of a bull
market and good economy
also relates to the growth of all these
and whether that
interacts in terms of the changes that
you foresee
the question is about the future of the
media uh the
impact of the bull market and what we
might see unfolding in the future
well this is sort of the part of a talk
where i want to say
you know i'm optimistic that things are
going to get better
but that would be wrong the fact is and
i cover
problems in the media in all guises in
my day job at the washington post
as the market speeds up and as the
ability to get information online speeds
up
and as the pace the seemingly breathless
pace of cable television
speeds up and there are more and more
channels and more and more choices and
more and more information
that in some ways is a boon for
investors but it also uh
creates more possibility for havoc for
misinformation for the rumors we've been
talking about
and it's hard for me to see uh
how news organizations which are under
incredible pressure with all this money
at stake
are going to resist the the urge
to get it out there before it's been
fully checked now i think some news
organizations
are slowly waking up to the fact that
their credibility is on the line
and to the extent that they um
are a little more careful sometimes a
little slower perhaps
willing to be beat by six minutes on a
story so that they can make sure the
story is right so they can get more
comments they can tell you more sides of
that story
but that is going to add to their
credibility and that might ultimately be
a better selling point than being the
first to shout into this
giant megaphone now how the financial
media are going to fair
uh if and when the bull market
eventually fades is an interesting
question that
um that a lot of people don't want to
face up to it's a lot of fun to check
your stocks every 20 minutes when the
thing is going up up up
it's a little harder to turn on cnbc
when all those arrows are in red
and when when the market is having a bad
time and obviously the market's been
quite up and down in the last six months
so it is certainly possible that if the
market goes into a slump or a prolonged
period where people are not
making a lot of money uh that's going to
hurt the ratings on television
that's going to hurt the traffic on
these websites and they will
um that in effect their
financial health is tied to some extent
to the the health of the market itself
which is the reason that some people
feel
that some of them kind of cross the line
to becoming market cheerleaders i would
like to see
news organizations which are after all
filled with some pretty smart folks
um figure this problem out exercise more
self-restraint
care more about the investor at home
than about the bragging rights
for getting the story 12 seconds earlier
that turns out to be
half-baked quarter-baked or sometimes
not put in the oven at all
and i think the more we move in that
direction uh the more we will emerge
with a stronger financial media
and that will be a benefit to consumers
who
may have their their hands on the
computer at home as well
i want to thank you all for coming
thanks very much
thank you very much
howard kurtz is the washington post
media reporter and the author of three
previous books
the fortune tellers is published by the
free press a division of simon
schuster for more information on the
book you can visit their website
simon says dot com
you